okay I am back it's very late
I usually don't record this light but
Marzia is in Italy this week and I
really want to make sure I can get a lot
of work done I know work this is my job
because Oh God and it you know back in
the day I used to play amnesia in the
middle of the night and I really feel
like this is bringing it back
oh god I am really it oh man I should
really should record all my stuff at
night cuz this is such a difference
playing it alone in the dark in an empty
flat there's the key there this really
brings me back man I also think oh man
it I'm I'm genuinely spooked out it's so
atmospheric um hurry I remember this
part I got really stuck here on the demo
there's like this one violin you're
supposed to find doesn't work right so
you have to hit the back now first we
have to find the LP I heard that that
the story is really good so I really
want to actually try and pay attention
to it I know a lot of times in horror
games recently they the story has just
been so bad that you tend to not really
like all around
something all around something all
around stumbling ever there something
everywhere in the world are you doing
what did the doctor say about straining
yourself leave that thing alone it's not
going anywhere
oh my god
god this is so creepy what is this
I needed a jar and a plastic tubing I
siphoned gas before I knew how it was
done I stuck the tube and a vein and
sucked on it until blood filled my mouth
then put the tube in the jar and it just
kept coming a taste of copper haunted me
the entire night why didn't I think of a
syringe why didn't I think of a syringe
I mean what was he doing trying to get
blood out of himself that's why is he
what's up with this guy
we had a wife we had a good life we have
good times in the mud and the shitty
this room kind of became a painting I
thought I could leave now it's hard
because I can't really [ __ ] see like
it's way too dark to look over here now
tell me I'm stuck again
maybe I need to play their song again
no no well then I don't know this is
strange I have a zooming option that's
good but honestly like it's too dark at
some place how could I possibly find
weird I I thought for sure I just have
to leave now so glitch perhaps such a
strange thing to get stuck on that maybe
trigger it no let's try that again
and we rewind nothing all around
something all around maybe they'll turn
it back
tumbler here and there something
everywhere and I declare yeah it's tying
it back on fall and when he [ __ ] my
school a school bus oh I fell and when I
roll
now we can Lee okay and we have another
core piece no toys on silent floaters
what are we doing what is all this there
we go
oh man what was that sound
alright so now we have the piece of
flesh first I alright developers you're
listening just ride it out yourself it
will look so much better
first I look for a canvas not just any
canvas I had to find a knife I wanted
out of them
those bread ones it needed to be as
sharp as a razor so I used a razor in
fact and then carefully pull it flayed
the skin booze helped to keep my hand
steady god damn that's disgusting I
needed a jar plastic tubing yeah okay so
we have four more items to find hate
even now lost alone you deserve it
a grape for you finish it's really
interesting really into this
so I remember correctly this room is
boarded off
or jab a lot of fun with that
god damn okay oh [ __ ] Jesus okay all
right we're fine we made it
probably a shitty really shitty piano my
pillow looks so comfortable I want to
sit on it all right we got here you got
anything good drug stash it's the piece
of [ __ ] what are you looking at
hey nice mustache looks like [ __ ] I
don't think I'm in any position to tell
anyone what their mustache looks like
well what are we supposed to go then oh
maybe back again it's weird how it does
that the game what happened yeah
[ __ ] is the closet haunting
mimics knock knock [ __ ] sake
hi guys nice lamp
but the graphics in in these games
they're just becoming better and better
so like I can't imagine playing again
like this with oculus rift in the middle
of the night like that would just be too
[ __ ] much or maybe that's just what I
need what is up with this [ __ ] room
there we go
yeah this is awesome there's been a lot
of jump scares so far but not no enemy
jump scares you know what I mean
no finites a fred is sucking on my teeth
yeah blooded [ __ ] god damn that was loud
I'm trying not to scream because it's
really loud and I think my neighbors
will be very angry but at the same time
it's really hard not to okay now we're
back here that place still look Oh
awesome
I hear a radio ignorant blind fool
in brain luckily uh you're a true
portrait so that's where I painted you
[ __ ] clamp [ __ ] man you kick some
artistic sense in your stupid face
that's what I say every time someone
just like my videos [ __ ] you potato man
you [ __ ] [ __ ]
I'm on your side man I get it
I'm with you right Bruce thank you
what's here then I like the limping it's
pretty cool I really feel like I am them
the character [ __ ] sake these doors oh
my god
well I'm trapped now does this game hate
me or something Oh what the [ __ ] is this
this must be new I don't recognize this
this is very creepy
I guess they watched a lot of Let's
Plays of like the demo and they they
kind of edited what worked and and they
kept what did that would make sense I
think that's cool I remember that the
amnesia crater Oh God
I'll tell you in a sec oh my god it's
coming from there
my god it keeps coming I don't know
where it's coming from
oh my god shut up
thank you this is super annoying you
know is it telling me to go back yes
hello hello yes speak your what what
fire hi oh god is she
which hospital I'm on my way
oh my god so they're Mischa guys they
want they told me that they wash a lot
of let's place to kind of get an idea as
well I would like what worked and what
didn't so I think that's cool that we
unknowingly helped I really want to play
so might as well but I figured this game
just came out so I'll do it first what
are your best thing do you want to see
soma I kind of I was away when it came
out that's why I didn't play it oh my
god
oh that's embarrassing oh my god [ __ ]
now I am understanding desk and my
reaction is to hide it underneath the
desk
it's [ __ ] the the wimpiest thing I've
ever seen but I it's my natural instinct
to hide like a little [ __ ] I can't help
it
oh here we go missus you can tell this
game borrows from amnesia in a lot of
ways but in a lot of good ways to the
lightening system you only see if you
were truly up close which i think is
cool god damn I'm so scared of the
monster they really did a good job
where are we
all this time okay we're back we're in a
dining hall okay we got light now that's
awesome um all the corridors Oh God
oh god what is that
Oh bok-bok-bok Oh Oh what happened oh
god your son oh god is that her
goddammit [ __ ] that [ __ ] am i right
dolphin alright let's go to hell
that reminds me that's the thing come
you did really well I don't know if you
remember they had it this hub area where
you could kind of like breathe out you
know they had the always build up
intention for this one area and then you
got to that and you can relax a little
bit they're really good pacing in horror
and this is really cool too but I'm I
remember when that elevator kind of fell
like that in any case as your lawyer I
advise you to refrain from any imprudent
actions in other words don't do anything
stupid we still have a chance of winning
this so there was a legal case ban like
the neighbor believe it or not we got in
clients out of deeper [ __ ] than this
just don't make it any worse lay low for
a while and let me babe let me appeal
the court order this social market
definitely has it in for you we can use
that to our advantage portray you as a
victim for the system a husband in
mourning a momentary
remember zealous bureaucrat trust me
this is our best option considering that
you been through lately I'd say we have
a good 50/50 chance of good outcome but
not if you keep trying to convince
everyone that you've gone completely
insane number outburst no more rambling
better yet no public appearances
whatsoever you can still get your
daughter back I assume that's what it
says oh god these empty corridors man I
don't like them think they're just for
loadings it's impressive how did I did
it for that [ __ ] did I just said
stepping around I have no idea what I
just stepped on you know what I'm just
not gonna go in there which is not gonna
do it what's over here bearer P if she
David God what happened I thought I went
inside oh here we go [ __ ] me suck piece
of [ __ ] [ __ ]
what is this a boss set I remember this
gem scare because it got me really hard
and I know they changed a 1.4 page zero
points four barrels oh that's nice
oh hey I wonder why I knew that was
gonna happen
he's a chef baby put down this toilet
seat you [ __ ] pleb what the [ __ ]
redecorating in like a second he's a
[ __ ] I'm glad I can move that because
otherwise I'd be stupid order dares are
trying a little piece of wood watch
right now let the main character doesn't
have arms who lights which but totally
works so well god damn I hope you bros
don't mind that I'm a lot more quiet
than usual maybe you think it's better I
don't know I just really want to play
right now I think that counts for
something which store this one yep got
it nailed it nailed it this is going
great
Oh what is happening why am i reacting
like that oh god [ __ ] the basement
basement [ __ ] sucks
god damn okay let's just keep going
I remember I played the piano and it's
really loud
[ __ ] this [ __ ]
well this is nice [ __ ] you gravity suck
a big fat dick gravity that's right
[ __ ] you barrel [ __ ] this is my
revenge this is my high-school emo song
musical wrench
[ __ ] think you know what I'm talking
about
hi even the candles oh I remember I got
kind of stuck in first time cuz
I didn't I don't know what I was in
Vista to just wait out the song I guess
it's fun to play with the gravity my
robot now what is this [ __ ]
Slenderman oh [ __ ] that is
very creepy I needed to remove the flesh
from the bone at first I was lost as to
how but then I sawed it off with a
handsaw boiled it then put the bone in a
mortar I had to get one obviously this
was not something I done before finally
I mix the dust with some white paint it
made for a lovely undercoat
[ __ ] wonderful just-just-just wonderful
just going to go now
thank you very much game it's been a
pleasure down here better god damn
that's a lot of stairs anyway how you
doing today it's very good very good
thank you thank you very much
yep totally and we got another key item
okay cool I suppose that means we're
halfway you will always be my grotesque
misunderstanding huh what if you fail
thanks thanks text of encouragement
let's ignore her oh [ __ ] what the [ __ ]
was that how can I ignore that [ __ ] oh
no I don't think I can no I don't think
I can uh oh yeah it's the baby part
let's go to home no yeah
selfish thanks thank you
alright alright alright what it what is
wrong alright maybe I wasn't the best
dad but you were a piece of [ __ ]
daughter alright how about that
that's a cool pone oh oh of course
lovely drawings I'm not gonna keep them
but guess you did it decent job oh it's
lovely she looks a little teddy
[ __ ]
how you doing teddy lock your hat hey
what is that
wait what day is it it's Sunday you mean
I oh well why didn't you come and get me
god dammit you know how I get when I'm
caught up in my work thank you for that
teddy
alright this is very useful very very
useful thank you very much I'm glad they
don't have [ __ ] tinderboxes swear to
God look Howard tinderboxes got so
[ __ ] old sorry Jesus
did you diss buy half of the department
store honey you don't even know yet if
it's gonna be a boy or a girl I like the
shoes I want to wear them I don't judge
all right sure you like to wear cute
things as well
that's a painting that's a real [ __ ]
nice painting mate hey the whole wall is
painted that wasn't even funny okay
awesome um haha okay what the [ __ ] is
this
Oh fine calm down man what did I ever do
to you I wish but if I were to explore
my cuz your missions everything okay I
don't know what to tell you man that's
beating hard and some prick good story
this is very helpful I don't know what
the heart represents maybe just a heart
I look broken oh the [ __ ] in there
hey girl
I think I died yeah definitely
or maybe not maybe I was supposed to go
there I don't know
suffer this what the [ __ ] whoa crayons
they're not supposed to fly that's cool
I suppose can I go home now oh and I
don't have to clean that [ __ ] up
oh [ __ ] a doll shut the [ __ ] up you
spoiled piece of [ __ ] oh my god god I
hate babies thanks now I hate babies
even more thanks game [ __ ] door
opening simulator right now jesus
[ __ ] christ
that's creepy I don't like it hey baby
how you doing gonna like gonna look you
all right what do we got in here
awesome babies that's me when I wake up
I don't know like I'm missing something
it's a button no goddamn my nose is ohe
oh hey what's your name Margaret
nice to meet you Margaret I like your
hat looks cool you like that [ __ ]
Margaret you feeling me Margaret
Margaret can you stop being such a
little [ __ ] right now I know you're I
know you're look hey someone someone's
emo am i right haha hey Marta Margaret
go Margaret for [ __ ] sake we talked
other UI okay ooh nice ass for a baby
look at that [ __ ]
someone's been working out their glutes
Margaret's still there
I can't see anything Oh
are they [ __ ] each other now
all right please don't touch me all
right
god I hate babies oh god that's a lot of
fun oh [ __ ] oh boy
I were fine look at that who has the
last laugh now Margaret ha me [ __ ]
[ __ ] Oh goddamn oh you [ __ ] pleb
I'm not going there
oh my god oh cool I'm glad we did that
I'm gonna go this way why is this a maze
ah you [ __ ] blend
my god can you stop being so [ __ ]
stupid
goddamn
okay what about this oh my god this is
so annoying I'm just gonna go straight
then Jesus Christ but you didn't like
that [ __ ] you didn't like that
at all
[ __ ] can't stop me I'm a force of
nature all right who the [ __ ] I'll
take it all back
you okay I'm not I'm really not the
[ __ ] sis
we're back at Margaret's house I'm gonna
take a break I'm really tired
I'll be more energized tomorrow but
thanks for watching really appreciate it
I hope you enjoyed and if you did go
ahead and leave a thumbs up and I'll see
you in the next one thank you so much
for watching and take care
bye